RE HEALTHCARE BENEFITSTHED
ADVANTE HE
T
I WANT TO BRING IN
CORRESPONDENT MAX FOSTERSIDE
YOU LEARNING? QUEEN HAS DIED.
SADLY.
FULLY ATRAL  AFTERNOON.
THE REFERENCE THERE TO CHARLES,
EVENING AND WILLN TO MES KING
LONDON TOMORROW.
I JUST RD ANOTHEE-MAIL.
N HAED.D LONG.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT H NAME WILL
BEKNOWD
PEACEFULLY AT LM THIS OON.
WHFIC NEWS FOR THE
NATION AND ONLINE
HOW PEOPLE FEEL WATCHING THIS.
BUCKINGHAM PALACT BEEN D SYMBOL
DEATH.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO SAYE NEWS
DRDING BUT OBVIOUSLY WHAHAPPENE
QUEEN DI AND THE FAMILRE
INFORMED AND HEADED UP TO
BALMORAL A TREPAY
THEIR RESPECTS.
THAT FOLLOWSERY CLEAR PROCESS
WE EXPECT TO THE KING
TONIIN TELEVISED ADDRESS
AND YOU'LL STA ING ACROSS LONDO
NATION.
I DON'T WANT TO GET INTO TOO LID
MUE ANS I'VE
SEEN BECAUSE THEY NEED TO BE
SIGNED OFF BY THE KING TRMALIZE.
WE'LL HEAR MORE  THE
G PROGRESSES.
QUEEN ELIZABETH HAS DIED AT  WH
MOMENT FOR THE USO4
OTHER NAOU  O NNS
THEONGEST
SERVING, I WOULD SAYT
REVERED HEAD OF STATE UNTIL SHE.
>> L ASK YOU, FO
ISROUGMUCH OF YOURCAREER.
YOU HAVE WATCHED THE QUEEN IN
GOOD TESES.RE YOUR THOU A HER
ABOUT HER LIFE, R UT HER REIGN
LEGACY?
>> I THINKWAY SHE DID WAS
EXTRAORDINARY.
SOMEHOINTO ONEONARCHY.HER  A EMH
OF THE MOST , ARGUABLY
THE MOST SUCCESSFU
BRITAIN HAS EV
H HISTORY. TUMUL
THREVOLUTION,  OF
SOCIETY.
SHE IS SOMEONE WE CAN'T RELA SE
SHE LIVED.THERE WERE VERY SIMPLS
THATE HELEVANT AND
RELATABLE.
SHE WAS ALSO THERE IN TIMES OF .
ANY NATIONAL MOMENT WE WOULD
LOOK TO HED SHE WOULD BE .
WE WOULD SEE AT R R THE URSEF
YEAR SO SHE THROUGH OUR
LIVES AND WAS ALWAYS THERE.
I K GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT IS FOR US NOT TO SEE
HER IN OUR ULTIMATE MOMENT OGRI.
WHICH IS DYINGWE WILL NOW LOOKNR
NG THEE CHARLES OR
HE CHOOSES ANOTH NAME.DETAILS WT
PALACE WHERE H BE, THE
FORMAL ANNOUNCEMENT WILL BMADE
AND THERE WILL BE REFERENCE TO
HIS NAME.W THAT CAMILLA IS NOW
SHE IS QUE CAMILLA.
PRINCE WILLIAMS NOW THE DU CORN.
HE WILL INEVITABLY BECOME THE P
SOMETHING, A TITLE THA
COME TO HIM.
HE OVER  AND NOW
PRINCE GEORGE IS LINE
THIS IS A  MOMENT IN
HISTORY ANMM STORY.
FOR THE WORLD.
BECAUSE I THINK SHE TRANS ENDEA
AND ONE WHO HAS ARANTEED
PLACE IN THE BOOKS.
I'M NOW LOOKING DOWN AT THOSE
PEOPATHEHOMBERWIE AND IT
WIVERY EMOTIONAL SCENE
AS THIS NEWS.>> CHRISTIANE?
>>TO HEAR MAX
DESCRIBE WHAT'S HAEN
KEEP USING T W C
OR, SORRY,
70 YEA
COUNTRY THE WORLD S ONLY
KNOWA QUEEN.
QUEEN ELIZABETH.
SHE WAS ONE OFA VERY
FEMALE MONARCHS OFS KINGDOM.
AN INCREDIBL ALONG
WITH QUEENA,EN
H I,T IS VERY
KNOW WHERE THCOUNTRY WILL GO FA
IT IS PROBABLY TOO EARLY TO EVEN
TALK ABOUT THIS NOW BUT WE ARE
IN A STATE OF CRISISE IN THE
UNITED KINGDOM LIKE
OE  BY
THE WAR IN UKRAINEY MAOD POVERTY
INFLATION.
PEOPLE'SNREST TO
MENTION CLIMATE WHS
VERY, BY THE WAY, D TO
ALONG WITH HER
96EA
IS WORLD RENOW
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT HOW SHE NEVER
Y INTERVIEWS S TERVIEW WITH HIM
SU EVENT.
SHE WAS IN HER OWN REALLY  IMPO
THAT ISSUE AS WELL.
DLIIN TERMS O ANDH
WHEN HER HUSBAND PRINCE PHILIP
DIED.
WEE E REG ON
HER, ON HIS FUNERAL.
IT WAS THE LAST TIMEE SAW THE
LY OUT IN PUBLIC.
YES, WE DID ON HER JUBILEE, BUT
N THE MIDDLE OF COVID.
SHE WAS ALL ON HER. PEOPLECULAT
THEN ABOUT SHE MIGHT
UE HER LIFE WIWHO WAS HER LIFE
NOT JUST PERSONALLY BUSOALLY.
AND SHD DECLINE QUITE
SIGNIFICANTLY AFTER THAT WITH OH
HICH, YOU KNOW, SH#96 YES OLD.
SOME TROUBLE
WALKING BUT SHE WAS SOFTG EVEN T
MONTHS, EVEN IN THE STE
PICTURE OF HER, GREETING HER
LATEST IHE
MINISTERLIZ TRUSS THE 15
PRIME ST COUNTRYE HEARD OM FMEP
MINISTERS JUST BEFORE THIS
ANNOUNCE W
TONY, DAVID CAMERON, FROM
DIFFERENT IEER
AND THE FAMILY WELL, CONCERNED
ABOUT THE NEWS THAT WANGOUT IN
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
KNOWN.SO PRESIDENT SHE HAS
SHE FIRST KNEW TRUMAN
AND ALL OF THE OTHER U.S.
PRESIDENTS ANDS.
HAS BED OF THECOMMONWETHS BEEN D
AD LAST 70 HAS GIVEN A MESSAGE
GU CONTINU